today we're going to talk about the
first symptom of a fatty
liver and that is blaze
now what is malate it's this general
discomfort
uneasiness type feeling you're feeling
like you're coming down with something
it's an absence of feeling good and
malaise is not very specific to a
certain part of the body it's kind of
all over it's kind of vague you're not
sure where it is
and you feel a little bit of weakness
what's happening
is your immune system is
activated there are cytokines which are
certain proteins that are activating the
immune system at a certain
level not enough for an infection
but just enough to make you feel like
you could be coming down with something
now malaise is many times also
associated
with fatigue but it's not fatigue but
the first symptom that occurs
with a fatty liver is malaise with the
second symptom being more right shoulder
pain
because the liver is on the right side
and when it starts swelling up
it can put pressure into the right side
and cause discomfort on the right side
now there are other causes of malaise
like an infection
or low blood sugar caffeine
withdrawal or the flu and of course
like i said a fatty liver once your way
to know that you have fat and liver is
just by
looking down and if you can't see your
feet because your gut is sticking out
you definitely have a fatty liver now in
the past i've created a lot of videos in
the liver so i put some links down below
of the most important ones with the
exact diet that you should be on
if you have a liver problem and in a
recent video i talked about adding
probiotics to your diet if you have a
fatty liver
because that is going to reduce the
immune response and you'll start feeling
better right away but there's a lot more
that can be done so if you suspect a
fatty liver
check out the links down below thanks
for watching
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help